- I DECIDED TO PULL A PRANK
THAT WOULD REQUIRE
A MASTERFULLY SUBTLE
AND CONVINCING PERFORMANCE.
[Italian accent]
EXCUSE ME.
IS THIS THE CLASSROOM
OF PROFESSORE ROMER?
- UH, YES.
CAN I HELP YOU?
- YES,
I'M FROM MORETTI'S DRY CLEANING,
AND I'M HERE TO DROP OFF
YOUR UNDERWEARS.
[laughter]
- I'M SORRY.
YOU'RE IN THE WRONG CLASSROOM.
PLEASE TRY THE BURSAR'S OFFICE.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
PROFESSORE.
I'M IN THE RIGHT CLASSROOM.
YOU REMEMBER, YOU DROP OFF
A PAIR OF UNDERWEARS WITH US
THAT HAD THE BIGGEST POOP STAIN
ON 'EM ANYBODY EVER SAW.
[laughter]
- OKAY, NOW, LOOK.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
SOME KIND OF A PRANK.
- OH, YOU KNOW WHAT,
THAT'S WHAT WE SAID
WHEN WE HAD A LOOK
AT THESE UNDERWEARS.
WE SAID, "SOMEBODY'S TRYING
TO HAVE SOME KIND OF A PRANK."
BUT IT WAS THE TRUTH.
- AND--AND IT'S
A STUPID PRANK TOO.
WHAT KIND OF DRY CLEANER
WOULD HAND-DELIVER
A PAIR OF UNDERWEAR
TO MY WORKPLACE, HUH?
- WELL, THAT'S--YES.
THAT'S A--THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
WHY WOULD SOMEBODY DO THAT?
- YEAH.
- WELL, DO YOU KNOW WHY?
I GOTTA LAY MY OWN EYES
ON THE GUY
THAT MAKE THIS BIG POOP STAIN
IN HIS UNDERWEARS.
[laughter]
IT'S A BIG POOP STAIN.
- PUT THE PHONES DOWN.
- YOU MUST HAVE HAD TO WEAR
THE SAME PAIR OF UNDERWEARS
FOR, LIKE, TWO WEEKS AND NEVER
TAKE OFF YOUR UNDERWEARS
TO MAKE THE POOP.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT,
PROFESSOR ROMER?
- I'M GONNA CALL
CAMPUS SECURITY, OKAY?
- THAT'S CRAZY.
YOU'RE CRAZY, PROFESSOR ROMER.
- DON'T SAY THAT!
- IT'S CRAZY!
WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A MINUTE,
WAIT A MINUTE.
- I'M NOT CRAZY!
- HERE'S THE ONLY THING
THIS GUY CAN TEACH
A CLASS ABOUT--POOP!
- GET OUT! GET OUT OF HERE!
- IT'S THE ONLY THING
HE CAN TEACH A CLASS--
- LET'S GO!
- OKAY, OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
HEY, HEY, HEY.
IT'S NICE
TO SEE YOU AGAIN, RANDY.
FORREST MACNEIL.
PAYBACK'S A BITCH, ISN'T IT?
- WHAT?
- ARRIVEDERCI!
[cheers and applause]